consumer elasticities have largely held
up better than expected year-to-date we
continue to expect more elasticity price
elasticity is a Hot Topic in earnings
calls during periods of high inflation
like the one we're in now when inflation
is high companies raise prices and
consumer spending usually slows as you
can see here consumer spending has held
up relatively well so far despite the
highest inflation in decades but experts
say we're finally reaching a turning
point where consumer spending is
beginning to slow and that's where
elasticity comes into play here's how
price elasticity works and why so many
companies are talking about it
how much does demand for something
change when the price changes when
something's elastic it means if the
price goes up demand Falls that's not a
great thing for companies because then
they have to worry about that any price
increase will really affect demands
here's the chief commercial officer of
Southwest Airlines talking about this
idea in the company's second quarter
earnings call Leisure Travelers have a
price list
what companies want is for their product
to be inelastic meaning a price increase
doesn't really impact demand
elastic products are usually
non-necessities like perfume and Staples
inelastic products are typically things
we really need and that don't have many
Alternatives like groceries and toilet
paper but there are some exceptions what
has proven inelastic particularly around
the pandemic has been branded household
goods in past kind of bumpy Economic
Times people have switched or traded
down to cheaper products around the
house a lot of people who really watch
the industry have been surprised by how
much people are willing to continue to
spend on these household Basics gym
memberships are also inelastic right now
for example Planet Fitness raised the
price of its black card membership in
May bringing the monthly fee for new
members up from 22.99 to 24.99 and the
company said in August we haven't seen
an initial dip in our Black Card
percentage rate as we did with past
price increases covid has eased up
everybody's kind of making up for lost
time they're wanting to get out so
they're spending on travel they're
spending on experiences and movies on
eating out and it's it's been a really
big shift from Goods to the service side
of the economy several factors affect a
product's elasticity it's the necessity
of the product so how important is it
you know what's the competition like are
there a lot of other options some of
it's just emotional you know some people
really believe a brand is a lot better
than another brand elasticity also
depends on the price range of the
product itself if it's a low-cost item a
slight increase in price matters to
Consumers if it's a more expensive item
then a small increase isn't as
noticeable these are examples of what
Executives consider when they talk about
elasticity
what Executives say and think about
elasticity matters a lot to Consumers
because ultimately their assessment of
what consumers are willing to pay will
drive their decisions on how much to
charge last year when CEOs were talking
about elasticity they were more saying
wow like everything's inelastic because
consumers are are just willing to spend
now prices are still going up because of
inflation but demand is starting to go
down so certain products are becoming
more elastic Unilever Procter and Gamble
and craft Heinz each reported lower
volumes in their latest quarters meaning
people purchase fewer brand items amid
higher prices many retailers have
lowered profit expectations for the year
and are cutting costs as consumers are
pulling back spending in categories like
apparel and Home Goods during the
quarter Macy's brand customers across
all income tiers slowed and shifted
their spend in recent weeks sales of
Premium detergents like tide have been
on the decline according to Industry
data after all this time of like
sticking to this very high end detergent
consumers are shifting to cheaper
detergent PNG Executives said they
believe Americans will keep spending on
household products even if inflation and
the overall economy worsen
so how can companies like PNG maintain
market share when their products become
more elastic one strategy is to promote
the cost-saving benefits of their
products and it'll save you up to a
hundred and fifty dollars a year and
it's cold there's a version of laundry
detergent that you can use in cold water
so the detergent isn't less expensive in
fact it's even more expensive than it
was six months ago but they say Hey you
know but the money You're Gonna Save on
not having to heat your water makes this
detergent like overall more cost
effective another strategy is to offer
smaller sized products at lower prices
to appeal to cash strapped consumers so
if you only have ten dollars you can
still get you know your name brand
detergent and that's something that
consumers who don't have as much money
do sometimes out of necessity it also
means they're actually paying more
for each you know quantity of the
product because the less you buy the
more expensive it is a PNG spokeswoman
says the company has always offered
various package sizes to meet different
consumer needs and those sizes vary by
retailer and Market craft Heinz takes a
similar approach by offering one dollar
Lunchables and lower priced packages of
Kraft singles cheese with fewer slices
companies also have the option to lean
on retailers to get more shelf space or
improve the presentation of their
products in the aisle
while inflation slowed a bit in August
underlying price pressures and wage
growth suggest it could run well above
the fed's two percent Target for some
time which is why industry leaders are
keeping a close eye on the labor market
the idea is that as long as people stay
employed consumer spending will likely
remain solid but supply chain
disruptions and consumer demand have
both shown signs of easing recently
which economists expect will slow price
increases for goods so the Dilemma for
many companies now is whether to raise
prices or cut costs when do we start
laying off workers so we don't have to
raise prices depending on the industry
some companies are there some companies
aren't there so I think figuring out
when that happens is where a lot of
companies are right now
[Music]